calme plat cet après midi au niveau de
la rn 9 et de l'échangeur de châteauneuf
qui voit pourtant passé en temps normal
près de 130 mille véhicules par jour les
usagers échaudés préfère éviter la zone
dont une grande partie est interdite à
la circulation et ceux qui n'ont pas le
choix se retrouve totalement englué sur
des itinéraires de déviation
comme ici à didot ou à khalis et déjà
l'impact économique est perceptible
c'est le cas dans cette entreprise de
transformation du métal
on envisage
une bonne demi heure trois quart d'heure
assez impossible
c'est impossible d'en voter par là
si j'ai un chantier a aussi dû n'y est
pas et ces jours ci à ce point oui on
est beaucoup moins facilement
atteignable donc aujourd'hui on se rend
compte qu'on a moins de clients qui
viennent nous voir directement parce que
simplement ils sont bloqués dans les
bouchons parfois certains font demi tour
les clients sont ici invités à
privilégier les mails ou le téléphone
pour leurs commandes et à ne se déplacer
que pour les récupérer dans cette
vitrerie la direction a carrément choisi
avec l'accord du personnel de
bouleverser les habitudes on à décaler
les horaires d'ouverture de 7h30 16h30
habituellement donc on a commencé à
travailler ce matin à 6 heures ce qui
fait que les professionnels ont pu venir
récupérer leur matériel entre 6 heures
et 16h30 pour pouvoir se rendre sur les
chantiers et notre personnel a pu
arriver et se rendent à leur travail dès
6 heures ce qui fait qu'ils n'ont pas eu
de problématiques d'embouteillage pour
se rendre à leur travail
de très nombreuses entreprises mais
aussi des infrastructures majeures comme
le porc sont devenues difficilement
accessible c'est donc véritablement
toute l'économie de la martinique qui
est potentiellement impactés
chaque semaine 700 à 900 camions entrent
et sortent du port chargé de bananes ou
de produits de grande consommation ou
julie c'est pour nous c'est une grosse
bertha parce que là aujourd'hui en terme
de rotations ne peut pas faire le nombre
de rotations possibles
vous avez avec tout ce qu'il ya comme un
depuis l'effondrement de l'activité
tourne au ralenti
on risque de fait à gosso mollo grand
maximum par jour à conteneurs les
autorités restent encore en attente du
diagnostic mais les travaux devraient
quoiqu'il en soit durer plusieurs mois
en attendant une voie pourrait peut-être
être ouverte provisoirement mais déjà
certains transporteurs et chefs
d'entreprise pose la question
d'éventuels dédommagements pour le
préjudice